hi everyone I'm here and I'm very happy
to be here to talk about a topic that is
many times overlooked and that once
adopted properly can be a game changer
and the ability to train and deploy
trustworthy machine learning models in
an efficient manner
so I'll start with a bit about myself
I'm a graduate of the IDF Scorpio
program which is an excellent excellent
program for technological leadership so
after about three years of training we
graduate like 50 people and then start a
relatively long career in the security
forces leading a quite uh Cutting Edge
Tech areas personally I started in unit
A200 did some low-level cyber research
and gradually I was lucky to continue on
transition to data science which since
then has become very close to my heart I
was working relatively where it was
still in the early days on on various
projects in the mainly for anti-terror
related use cases and it was really a
great challenge to see both the value
from the machine learning models and
also the different challenges in making
them uh gradually more adopted
and uh being able to like verify that
they're more trusted by their users and
how do they scale how do you verify they
work properly and that was a big
motivation for uh founding deep checks
along with Philip my co-founder and in
deep checks in general we work the
notion of a continuous validation for
machine learning models so it means um
from training uh to deployment uh to
also have a commercial product in our
monitoring uh monitoring and production
debugging and as you probably understood
by now this is a topic that is very
close to my heart it's how to verify and
validate and how machine learning models
work better and we're exactly going to
talk about about that
um so just a bit more about me when not
training models I love training in
general
um more standard Sports is uh running uh
which I actually just came back from a
run which is nice and also with the
standards sports like kite Surf and
skiing and if you wander around the
streets in Tel Aviv you may see me on my
unicycle either the electrical one or my
non-electrical one
um so I wanted to start with a short
example
um this is a paper from 2017.
um it was published by a prestigious
research group in Stanford led by Andrew
Eng and the topic was they they built a
network to diagnose pneumonia
of course this it it worked great and it
hit the headlines and everything
everyone was really happy and again
tooth yeah um you can see November 2017
only if we go a bit into the details of
the paper
um and thank you Santiago for this tweet
just for actually I saw this just so
recently so we have here like the area
describing how they built the training
set and what exactly was used so we can
see that we have 112 000 x-ray images
which is fine from from 30 000 patients
so we understand that there's like more
than uh more than one image for for at
least some of the patients which is not
a problem but if we look at how the data
set was split we can see it was randomly
split
um into 80 training and 20 Foundation
wait so we had the same patience that
some of them appeared both in the train
and also in the test data sets this
doesn't sound that right I mean seems
like there was a potential here for
basically some sort of leakage maybe it
didn't like we don't exactly know maybe
the model could have used some patient
specific things to actually understand
what happened especially if uh slightly
that the same x-ray images maybe were in
the indications of the same thing
so in this case by the way it was fixed
so what you see here is uh is a new
paper that was published like some time
after it in which they you can really
see that they randomly split the data
into training with like uh some of the
patients only in training and some of
the patients only in in foundation and
test and they emphasize that there is no
patient overlap between the sets
but of course if if this can happen in
such a you know so many researchers and
such a well-known group and um uh and uh
it was only it was only actually uh
covered
um discovered a bit later we can
understand that these sorts of problem
may be something you want to look and
think a bit about
and if we look at this slides we can we
can see that there were really many
additional problems that machine
learning models face when they're not
properly validated so um I won't go to
all of these but uh you can't check out
we have a nice blog post uh talking
about many of the of the known machine
learning uh failures of course these are
only the publicly known ones
um there are also many additional ones
that you know just like internally in a
company there was some problem and then
they discovered it so um this leads me
to the topic of our talk so we're going
to talk about testing and how to
properly test start with a short
introduction about how it's looking
software because essentially machine
learning is some type of software and
it's a well known and developer
methodology
dive into testing machine learning so
what are the challenges the specific
types of problems how to approach it
what should we test how should we test
and when to test for it and we're going
to touch about some tools for actually
incorporating it into your machine
learning workflow
so a bit about software tests if you
look kind of along the years this is a
field that gradually evolved like it
started with a manual QA at the end of
the development process and there's lots
of methodology today that really helps
us do it much more um as part of the
development process we put a lot of time
for it it's the responsibility of
whoever develops the code and it's
really basically helping us build much
more um much more agile code with
quicker iterations and trustworthiness
and experiment is it's a well-known kind
of a form of like uh different types of
tests so unit tests for for more
specific things and as we go as we go up
the pyramid we're like testing
um the the system in uh in bigger
Granite granularity so what this comes
to think about is so how and why should
we do it in machine learning so well
about why there's many many good reasons
um starting from mitigating lots of
known risks that we have because machine
learning pipelines are complex with lots
of moving parts and obviously as we saw
and as we probably are familiar with
they break it's going to help us improve
our process so
um retrain models and deploy them much
more quicker and of course increase our
own and our users trust in our models
and the real reason I want to talk about
this and it's so important and also
generally working in the field is that I
feel it's super important when you do it
properly you can really improve a lot
and sadly it's not that common so it's
not that it's not common at all but
really there's there's a lot to to
advance and improve in that area
so um we're gonna dive in
um if any of you were wondering okay so
why shouldn't we just do the same things
as we do in software or isn't aren't the
challenges essentially kind of the same
so I would want to pinpoint a few of the
big differences which makes it really in
my opinion
um both quite challenging and also a bit
harder to sometimes use some of the
existing methodologies
so in software
um essentially what changes is the code
right so maybe you added some things
where you changed things but you can at
least track it and see what exactly
changed while machine learning you have
both lots of many parts and also the
code just builds a model and then the
model is the one that that that's
running and it obviously changes
um completely so how how do you compare
that or how you make sure you covered
like all of the for example changes in
the new model
when we look at the concept of coverage
so in software you can at least kind of
see which areas of the like which
branches of code you covered and it
gives you some aspect of how well this
code is tested or how complete while in
machine learning it really doesn't exist
like what is coverage or am I trying to
cover the input space or rather like the
different um uh weights or
um so I can't really like make sure I
covered everything or or I can't really
even get an estimation of of what is the
percentage of what I cut
and um my favorite one or more more
likely like the most painful one in my
opinion is that it tends to fail
silently so the pipeline doesn't tell
you like okay you know this value now
changed and um continue to to send over
values but they're just not right
anymore I mean the model will give a
prediction and the prediction will go on
and no one comes and says like it
doesn't just break I mean if it would
just break or in many of the cases it
doesn't just end sometimes that would be
much better because at least we would
know and here we can really have a like
gradually incurring problem and loss
over time
so
where does this meet us like in our um
for example work as data scientists so
we're gonna look at a short story about
Tom
Tom works at a company developing a
smart and adaptive firewall and he's
really excited to work on a new project
they're going to work on bottle
detection so essentially the model needs
to classify whether like certain packets
of traffic are from Human Source or from
a bot Source this is very interesting
for the company because they want to be
able to like a divert to bot traffic and
not allow things like scraping up their
websites and so forth
and um since Bots are quite quite uh
frequent so they have like the metrics
the target metrics for this project are
it has to achieve a very high recall so
we really want to like over 0.99 so we
really want to um be able to like uh
catch almost all of the Bots or like a
very high percentage of the Watts as
your point nine um like 99 and for the
Precision well we don't like what
happens is if a bot is detected then
it's um divert like it's diverted to a
capture now if a human is never is moved
to a capture then it basically hurts
conversion so you wouldn't want to like
just send all the humans over to a
captcha because you would um get less
interaction with your website and
therefore also position is very relevant
and here the target was on 0.8 so let's
look at uh Tom's project
he worked on he collected um lots of
data from different sources like they
have some kind of um you know um thing
in the like a toolbar and that collects
different data and they have some proxy
and firewall so he got he got lots of
like different fields of data about the
traffic in the packet from different
areas in the Lake of the product of the
company
then he went on to try building a model
so he split the train and test and did
some pre-processing
and once he had like an initial model
that that looked good he decided that
I'm looking at like the Dynamics of the
traffic and how it changes the best idea
is to retrain it every day and so the
internet is very Dynamic and to use the
last eight days of traffic or to train
um one of the reasons for that is that
there is some like um typical behavior
for certain days and then if you take
the last eight days you get like twice
the same day so that was he saw that
that achieved um good results when like
looking historically
and finally this model was trained on
lots of different websites but when used
in production it was also used um like
for serving also on new websites that it
wasn't trained specifically on them
so
um this is a happy story and uh you know
Tom finished and trained a great model
uh achieved the targets he needed and
the model was deployed to production
um so maybe I can end my talk
or
not really wait what happens here
um so what you see here is the model's
real recall on Precision after the after
it was in production for for some time
um unlike the the stats we saw before
which was what Tom thought like after he
did the the test set and saw like with
the model Chiefs so it was a really big
gap between what uh what they thought
um was going to happen and reality so
what's could have gone wrong let's have
a look at the different phases
so for the data source um we said that
there's like different uh types of tools
developed by different teams and what
happened here was there was an API
update of one of the different like
tools that collects um uh different uh
the results and the number was
calibrated differently so instead of
being between zero to one it was
suddenly between 0 to 10. so again the
model continued to work but basically it
was uh receiving like irrelevant values
so we had here a data Integrity problem
for the uh the train test split
um this may remind you of something a
bit from before so without noticing you
put um the traffic from the same unique
uh devices or in this case like the same
unique sources in both of the of the
most of the train and both the test
therefore this also was basically some
sort of leakage and uh showed us
essentially higher results on a test set
than than in reality
about the model retrain so this sounds
fine right like what is the problem here
so what Tom didn't know was that uh
there was a uh marketing just launched
uh some campaign so it was marketing
like of the website they were they were
serving
um or a various website they they
launched a campaign targeted for Android
users so what happened was that there
was much more traffic coming from
Android than before of course this
change of behavior suddenly the model
just didn't didn't behave
um like they could differently or
basically predicted on different data
and many of the Android users were
classified as a Bots instead of though
they were just like uh human beings
coming out from from the source of the
campaign
[Music]
um so this is a sort of data drift in
this case there was a reason for it but
essentially it's just a difference
between the distributions on the data it
was trained and when I was in production
[Music]
and serving familiar and unfamiliar
websites so what does that mean like
does will the model essentially
generalize properly for all of them
maybe upon different segments um the
performance varies a bit and that is
really what happened like on the website
said it it already knew it worked good
also on some of the new websites but not
on all of them
so if we can um like if we look together
at all of the different uh problems that
in this case they weren't necessarily
all discovered exactly on the same day I
mean when they start to understand okay
what's wrong here so uh after quite a
tedious process of research they
understand different problems that
happened and and really eventually were
able to improve the model and the
performance also in uh production but
this is a kind of a longer motivation
story about where it can meet us and how
we see it um in reality so we're gonna
now move to talk about how to approach
it so we thought that we'll stick talk
about the challenges and then now about
them what should we check what are the
types of problems um where should we
work on it in the pipeline and so forth
so we'll start with the simplest
question in my mind which is what should
we test so like we said there's lots of
moving parts and each of them affect so
let's have a look what do we have here
so in our machine learning model paper
and essentially we have data we have the
process um the pipeline building the
data analyzing it building the model and
we have the model itself and also as we
saw in Tom's example
um we have also um things from the
environment that affect us whether it's
like things like a marketing campaign or
just like the Dynamics of your
environment how how quickly it changes
and we may have some various constraints
uh for example business constraints
um only in reality it's a bit more
complex because these things really
greatly affect each other I mean the
model is obviously built on the data and
the process and so forth and that's one
of the reasons we're gonna now try to
like make it a bit more organized and
understand okay so what what exactly are
we going to to test so in order to know
what to test I want us to have a look on
what are the types of problems so I
mentioned a few examples let's see
typically what are the different types
or areas of problems so the three groups
um the three typical groups are things
that have to do with the data so
specifically like the data's Integrity
for example a missing values changes in
the strings um maybe incorrect labels
for example this is something that is a
like a data Integrity problem which is
very specific to machine learning models
just like in in general data you don't
necessarily have labels and therefore um
so it's there's like a wide variety of
data typically problems somewhere more
General like formatting consistency and
some are really relevant to the fact
that there is a model that is going to
be trained on the data according to
labels
there is um data distribution problems
um just changes or or leakages drifts
and so forth and things that have to do
with the model's behavior for example um
does it degrade over time
um uh how does it uh behave across
different segments is it calibrated and
so forth and I don't want to overwhelm
you overwhelm you too much so I'll just
show this for a second this is a very
partial list of types of problems that
um we've seen or are familiar with and
also uh um recommend testing for and
I'll touch a bit more
um let's look at the two a two or a few
specific examples of how it actually
looks so in this case like we have a
loan model we're trying to classify or
decide whether whether a loan should be
approved or not and we have various data
like age income what is the amount of
the loan and so forth and
um the model gave some some prediction
and we have here another another sample
uh those of you that are sharp eyed
maybe already know notice the difference
which is United States so actually there
isn't even a difference it's only
written differently but if if this is
something that we didn't catch in a
pipeline then it like for example let's
say we have one hot encoding and we
didn't first normalize the strings so
this will be considered as a probably
different like new category and
accordingly also you can see that the
prediction is different which is very
weird it could be what obviously um
expect a similar prediction and this is
the type of problem that we call a
string mismatch
um another example is well I already
popped here up the the difference which
is you see here that the only thing that
changed between the two samples is that
instead of female it's male and again
the prediction is very different here
it's a matter both of what is the
training data and what is our policy and
how how do we verify these types of
things for example if we want to make
sure that the model behaves uh similarly
on a different demographics so this is
an issue we should take into
consideration
and they'll give also a computer vision
example I'll say something kind of
General we do see that the same types of
problems appear in different types of
use cases and different types of data
whether it's a tabular computer vision
NLP
um obviously for some of them the
algorithms for actually catching them or
how do we analyze it and how do we
verify my times implementation is
different because we're processing a
different type of data but it's quite
surprising to see that it's essentially
the same the same areas and same types
of problems so maybe some of you are
familiar with this example it's uh from
um from a famous paper called the why
should I trust you and here we had a
relatively simple classification model
that is trying to um determine whether
whether the animal is a wolf or a Husky
and they got really really good accuracy
score and
um what did happen here though is that
once like I mean initially okay good
accuracy so great we can continue right
but when the when the misclassifications
were inspected they noticed that what
actually happened was that there was a a
big effect of the background or in this
case like a snowy background on what was
actually predicted by the model and
essentially so you can see like for
example here on the on the bottom one on
the right
um I'll ask you was predicted to be a
wolf and it's really on a snowy
background so in this case we have a
like really good model theoretically
with good performance but think about it
what if it's now like deployed on on
North Pole right so probably it won't be
actually that's good and really
distinguishing between uh huskies and
wolves as as we um believer thought it
was
so
we understood that there's different
types of problems but how do we approach
it like what should we test and sadly if
you Google it probably you won't find
too many um results like you have
different ideas or or implementations
but but it's really like not that well
built and we're now gonna like kind of
go over the different uh parts hopefully
by the end of the lecture you won't need
to feel lucky and you will have the
tools to um to really kind of start
working on it
so what should we test so we have we
should understand what are the inputs we
want to test what are the type of checks
like what do we actually want to check
for when do we want to do it in the
process and
um some is there some like
methodological way or how do we really
incorporate it
so about what should we test so we saw
this kind of uh beforehand if we really
look at what are the things we
understand that there's essentially
three things there's the data everything
that has to do with the data everything
that has to do with us splitting the
data whether it's trained tester also
for example in production it's like okay
they're training data versus the
inference data um so any kind of uh
batches or data splits and things that
have to do with the model
um so these are the inputs let's and we
have here like a list of checks if we if
we kind of organize it to the more high
level one we have here the different
um uh like types of titles or groups of
checks so
um I will give a few examples of okay so
we understood there's a problem here so
how it acts but how do you find it so I
will say that in general in deep text we
have a open source package which you're
welcome to use and of course you can
also implement the the test in any other
way you choose I'm just going to show
like the different types of problems
that uh that we saw and how how they
would look or in this case with with um
with the checks
so um remember the the leakage that we
had of the same patients in uh in uh
different data sets we can train both in
test so in this case what we can do of
course we have to think about it and
Define it but we can verify that there
aren't the same for example indices both
in like if each each patient has a
unique index so that they don't have the
same indexes both in train and both in
test and in this case we see that um
like uh running this check and we see
that in some in in some cases they do
so for the wolf versus husky um we did
something similar we like we took a data
set in this case these are a few
pictures from the data set and what we
saw is we tried to see if there are any
other like meta like Properties or a
kind of meta data about the picture that
can help us um help us identify or are
highly correlated rather with the label
and in this case what we see here is
that there are a few
um indications for example how green the
picture is or how bright it is highly
correlated with the label now this
doesn't necessarily mean that the model
is wrong with that there's a direct
problem but it is something that we want
to further um kind of delve into
[Music]
a string mismatch so well we can check
in and verify that all the strings are
the same
um feature drift like in the targeted
the marketing campaign so we can really
both look at a whole data set kind of
level or per feature and see wait if we
compare these like train test Clips do
they are there is their distribution the
same and for example in this case we can
have like a sort of aggregated drift
score and and and verify that um
um it behaves as as we expected to or we
meets a too high of a drift
um week segments performance is
something before when we saw wait does
does my model behave the same on
different areas so in this case
obviously we all check like the overall
um you know metric and performance but
we can verify how does it look across
different segments whether it's segments
we we Define like manually on specific
demographics or also automatically find
segments that are weaker and compare
their performance
[Music]
um and so this is again like the higher
level
um list and my real tip is to think
about this uh record regarding your your
domain your specific task and to build a
checklist I can also recommend like
think about what is what what do you
want and also if you saw some type of
problem that like uh uh in the past then
you would obviously want to add it to
your checklist and what I recommend in
this case is um also feel free to check
out our docs we have quite a long list
of uh checks and problems that can give
you some inspiration
um about when should we test so my short
answer to this is as soon as possible
essentially
um if we look at a machine learning
pipeline we have the research phases we
have the decision to deploy it and maybe
some type of cicd process and the
monitoring part and what what is quite
typical like and that was something that
was very surprising for me is that we
saw the companies that are monitoring
their models but not necessarily
elaboratively testing them before
they're deployed so the idea here is as
early as possible and some of it can
already be done in the research for
example once we have um like already
data we can check the data and once we
have some initial pre-processing we can
compare like the different splits and
once we have the model we can evaluate
it and so forth
so the last thing I didn't uh touch uh
deeply yet is What's missing
how to actually do it how to incorporate
it one of the reasons I didn't touch it
is that here there isn't a very clear
direct answers answer it's really more
dependent on your use case what are your
challenges and how it looks I will give
them a few considerations so for example
the test can be automatic and like run
as part of the cicd or they can be
manually inspected
she have a clear past field status maybe
some of them shouldn't maybe some of
them need again some like manual
inspection to verify is this what I
expect
are they run like once or is it
something that we want to constantly
check for example when the model's in
production so every day
how are we going to verify the results
is it like a peer review process is a
manager or like a data science team
leader checking along with the team or
is it against some like in a automatic
process
and something that really helps is how
reusable are they so if we have a good
base of code and a good methodology and
framework then we can uh it can be much
more efficient to test um widely
and since it may be a bit overwhelming
maybe like a big tip would be to start
with setting up a testing process for uh
for at least one of the phases where
it's more critical and uh after you're
you feel comfortable with it like one
feeds in the process whether it's uh for
example in cicd
um or on specific like every time you
get new data and uh then continue on and
really elaborate it because uh I do feel
it's uh it's one of the most essential
Parts in uh really building uh good
models that work over time
so a short um some tools that you can
later kind of Google or think about and
how to incorporate it um if relevant in
general I split them to two types one is
for running and automating tests and the
other is for actually building the test
so when um automating we have probably
some of you know like python testing
Frameworks for example a pi test or a
hypothesis workflow management tools
more for the engineering side of like
airflow for timing different processes
or also CI CD to really run it for
example for every new model version
um such as GitHub actions and circle CI
and for building the test
um there are a few tools for data
Integrity I think there's also at least
the one talk about the Great
Expectations um in this conference and
uh and Padero and um for ammo testing
I'm I'm happy to say that though uh like
a year ago there wasn't anything
um out there so today with lots of help
and contributions from the community and
lots of feedback uh I'd love to if you
do use to to hear it to hear your
thoughts and also welcome up with
contributions
um and I also give some examples from
Deep checks so
short summary
um testing machine learning is important
there's lots of recurring types of
problems
uh we recommend you start like thinking
about the inputs what exactly you check
when you do it and insert it into your
process
checking the data the splits and your
model
and really throughout the life cycle at
least eventually
so
um on that note I'd want to thank you
for for listening hopefully I'd love to
see you in our community or in general
I'd love to hear your thoughts about uh
about testing and about different
problems that you face and how you've
solved them and it's also a good
opportunity to say to say yeah a big
thank you to the community and feel free
to reach out you can scan the QR code
for more details about how to how to
reach out to me and um that's it for now
I think I have maybe like one minute so
if there's any open questions I'd be
happy to to answer
ah thank you sure I think this is a very
important topic that uh we need to I've
always thought that we need to do more
of uh so let's uh very quickly go for
one more question
um so this is from Bruno uh you
mentioned a couple of differences
between software and ml testing uh
another one of them is Randomness uh do
you have any suggestions on how to deal
with it
threat I'd split it into two one is I
think in some places where it's relevant
try to really make sure that it's uh
your pipeline is repeatable so for
example if you want to verify compared
to some golden uh set or something like
that then make sure to you know uh put a
random seat in place and things like
that on one hand and on the other hand I
think that really dealing with
Randomness is being able to do like
different types of of uh like not don't
only check it once but for example check
different splits and you know then check
also the variance between them and
things like that so like take into
account the randomness know that it's
random and then think how to verify your
system albeit the randomness